on Wednesday morning President Trump
tweeted out his most important offence
to accusations about Donald Trump jr.
attempting to collude with the Russian
government
hey but Hillary he tweeted why aren't
the same standards placed on the
Democrats look what Hillary Clinton may
have gotten away with disgraceful this
has become the all-purpose alibi for
Republican malfeasance some call it what
about ISM what about Hillary Clinton
what about the media what about Bill
Clinton or Teddy Kennedy there's a
raging debate on the write about the
nature of this defense is it just excuse
making for bad behavior or is it a
legitimate reminder that politics is a
dirty game and we don't choose the rules
of engagement this morning Byron York of
the Washington Examiner explained
another word for what about ISM is
precedent this seems kind of inadequate
what about ISM actually takes three
basic forms some of them useful
some of them counterproductive let's run
through them first reminders of leftist
dishonesty when Trump tweets out that
Hillary Clinton may have gotten away
with that behavior he's always partially
reminding the media and the Democrats
that they were fine with Hillary's bad
behavior when conservatives spent much
of yesterday reminding the media the
Barack Obama pledged flexibility to the
Russians in exchange for them backing
off their aggression in the final days
of the twenty twelve election they were
doing so in order to point out the
media's obvious leftist bias that's
important and it's worthwhile but it
should be made explicit second
what about ISM can be a reminder of
proportionality sometimes what about ISM
takes the form of reminding people that
something isn't that big a deal
seemingly the entire left went ballistic
this week when it first heard about a
house rule that forbade bear arms in the
Capitol the right promptly recommended
reminded the left that this rule existed
under Nancy Pelosi - it wasn't a big big
deal then it's not a big deal now third
moral relativism now this is the
dangerous form of what about ISM it's
also the most common this is the actual
message underlying Trump's tweet Hillary
got away with it so why shouldn't I be
able to get away with it this ignores
two crucial facts first Hillary did not
get away with it she lost the election
it's why she's not in the White House
second wrong is wrong the right now
engages in a fantasy whereby the left's
dishonesty somehow justifies
conservative dishonesty hey if Hillary's
corrupt what's the big problem with the
Trump campaign soliciting information
from the Russian government in this case
what about ISM is it self dishonesty
it's pretending to care about the sins
of the left in order to justify the sins
of the right it actually throws into
sharp relief the hypocrisy of the right
we complained endlessly and justifiably
about Loretta
meeting secretly with Bill Clinton but
we're fine with Donald's from jr.
meeting secretly with mentality of
vessel mates kya and we're supposed to
believe everything he says about it we
ripped President Obama's flexibility hot
mic moment but we're fine with President
Trump saying that America is killing
people just like Putin we correctly
targeted Clinton over China gate but now
we're happy to use China gate as an
excuse to avoid talking about Russia
gate
this isn't conservative it's not even
moral kindergarten kindergartners learn
that that learned that but he did it to
isn't an excuse for bad behavior we
should know this stuff the right often
embraces this form of what about ISM
because many people believe that
fighting the left requires tossing out
morality of means in favor of morality
event fight fire with fire since that
was the animating principle behind a lot
of conservative support for the Trump
campaign this form of what about ISM has
also become the most common form many on
the right say this isn't actually moral
relativism relativism implies there's no
moral answer to any given question where
a situational morality says there is a
moral answer but a change is based on a
fact pattern therefore it might normally
be wrong to collude with Russia for
example but it's a moral imperative to
do so to stop Hillary Clinton after all
we have decided with Stalin to defeat
Hitler we made us decide with Putin to
stop Isis the problem is that this
invites an obvious temptation if you can
turn the other side into Hitler you can
make excuses for siding with stone in
the game of politics you are willing to
honestly assess the moral quality of
their opposition and the rules of
engagement it's far more politically
profitable to define all political
enemies as Nazis and then suggest it's
okay to punch them this is just as true
for the left as it is for the right far
more for the left actually it's always
easier to win if you side with Stalin
even if you could win without siding
with Stone the temptation therefore is
to demonize the other side so you can
side with Stalin even if you don't need
to we ought to be careful about how we
use what about ISM the goal should be to
reinforce moral standards not to
undermine them but that goal seems to be
receding into the distance as we use
what about ISM as a club directed a
destroying principle rather than a
shield for defending it i'm ben shapiro
this is the venture Pierrot
okay we are going to fully analyze
everything having to do with Trump jr.
and his threes and then the roof Ian's
we're going to get to all of that plus
you see this magical cup I've been
informed I must show this cup to you as
often as possible this unbelievable
tumbler okay it's not like that men's
tumbler but it is just almost as cool
it's an incredible tumbler this
incredible tumbler can be yours but I'll
explain later on the show why that is
okay so I'm going to tell you about
everything Trump jr. or later we're
gonna go through the tape we're going to
talk about Democrats completely losing
their minds over this and they have lost
their mind over everything so far we
will go through all of that but before
we do that I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at helix Lea so you
are a unique human being you don't walk
like everybody else you don't talk like
everybody else why should you sleep like
everybody else your mattress should be
custom-made for you helix sleep comm
make sure that happens you answer a few
simple questions when you go to helix
sleep comm they're on a 3d biomechanical
model of your body through an algorithm
they've designed with the help of the
world's leading organ and biomechanics
experts and it is the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept down we had a
more expensive mattress actually and
then we got our helix sleep mattress we
took that other mattress and put it in
the other room because our helix sleep
mattress is so good and you can even get
a helix sleep mattress that has two
separate sides to it so if you and your
spouse have different preferences in
mattress then you can still share one
mattress but the two sides sleep a
little bit differently they send it to
your house you take it out of the box it
inflates right away it's a foam mattress
and you can just use it it's really
really cool everybody from GQ to Forbes
are talking about helix sleep and
they're in helix customers reported 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality you
also have a hundred nights to try it out
so if you don't like it you can send it
back and they will give you a 100%
refund so it is a risk-free proposition
go to helix sleep calm slash Ben and you
get $50 off your order
that's helix sleep calm slash then again
that helix sleep calm slash Ben and that
ensures they get 50 bucks off your order
plus they know that we sent you ok so
last night Donald Trump jr. appears on
Sean Hannity's program and there are
five big questions about Donald Trump
jr. meeting with the Russian story so as
I recall yesterday these blockbuster
emails are released by Donald Trump jr.
on Twitter and he wasn't doing it out of
the goodness of his heart ok Trump said
my son is so tricky
unbelievable transparency a
waverly conceived roomies like a glass
of water you can see right through him
unbelievable people okay but it turns
out the reason that he revealed the
emails is because eight minutes later
the New York Times ran a story on the
email so he knew the New York Times is
going to reveal the story so he threw
the emails out there the problem is that
the email said explicitly that Rob
Goldstone who is that weirdo we played
on the show yesterday this publicist
weirdo who talks about andy's RB or
whatever whatever does he that guy
brokered a meeting between Trump jr. and
a Russian connected lawyer whom he said
was a Russian government lawyer and he
also said this is part of Russia's
effort to support mr. Trump his direct
quote from the email quote part of
Russia and his government support from
mr. Trump so the left immediately jump
to this is the collusion the collusion
has happened collusion has occurred from
two years saw this and he said he loved
it and then he brought in metaphor they
brought in Kushner and this is where the
collusion began the evil planning in the
back rooms to decide how to militarize
all of Hillary Clinton's seized emails
from WikiLeaks and John Podesta seized
emails from WikiLeaks okay that is not
what actually the emails show what the
email showed was attempted collusion
okay first of all no collusion is a term
of art is not a term of law collusion is
not a crime there is no crime called
collusion there's a crime called
conspiracy to commit a crime but there
is no crime called collusion okay not
when it comes to this kind of stuff so
when people say collusion and you go
he'll end up behind bars no no you have
to have to commit a crime under statute
in order for you to end up behind bars
so it can still be bad it can still be
wrong it can still be a political
problem it can still be an impeachment
problem for President Trump if the
Democrats ever god forbid got controlled
the House of Representatives but it is
not actual legal crime okay this is not
legal crime so we can put that to the
side but what the Democrats were saying
that this was the beginning of actual
collusion this is where they started
coordinating okay well there's no proof
that actual coordination actually
happened because all of the people in
the meeting came out and said that was
worthless do the ladies even have any
information they're a couple of threats
that exist even if the information was
worthless threat number one was that
this was sort of the opener that the
Russian government now knew that the
Trump campaign was willing to hear more
stuff and so maybe there would be
collusion down the road but we haven't
found any evidence of that
threat number two is that now that
there's been this meeting they can hold
that over Trump's head right they could
the Russians could hold this over
Trump's head they could say anytime we
want we can drop the information that
you are quasi colluding with us or
trying to collude with us and destroy
your presidency but now the information
has been dropped so the threat is a
little bit gone unless there are more
shoes to drop but there are some
outstanding questions that I want to go
through about this particular meeting
and I think they actually do require
answers now because they are things that
the Trump is going to be asking the
Trump administration are going to be
asked to number one did any information
actually pass hands so everybody at the
meeting as I say Kushner Paul Manafort
the then campaign manager the Trump jr.
vessel mitts kiya Natasha wood Natalia
whatever her name is all of them say no
information changed hands the problem is
you wouldn't expect them to say
differently right who and that meeting
is going to say yeah they give us a
bunch of information about Hillary
Clinton then we used it no one's going
to say that right that's one that Skye
would have to then admit that she was
basically an agent of the Russian
government and the other three people in
the room would actually be in danger of
prosecution if the information was
illegally obtained so none of them are
actually going to say it and they all
have a little bit of a history of
dishonesty with this particular matter
Manta port has been a Kremlin stooge for
years the I mean when going back to 2012
there there's a guy who approached me
about working with Manta fort and was
basically posing him as a stooge of the
Ukrainian government at the time so this
is not any sort of great shock at that
time the Ukrainian government was in
league with with Vladimir Putin Trump
jr. had fibs about the meeting he said
it didn't take place and he said it
didn't take place but we talked adoption
and then finally he admitted what the
meeting was about Kushner did not put on
his forms of this meeting ever took
place so maybe I was oversight maybe it
was dishonesty but at least calls trust
into question and we have no idea who
this Veselin that Skye lady is right I
mean she says she's not a Russian agent
but there's evidence to suggest that she
is a Russian what they call a cutout
which is to say somebody who works for
the Russian government but has plausible
deniability so we just don't know if any
information was passed in this meeting
and the reason that I say this is
because you know if you if you look back
to here's from jr. this is clip debris
Trump jr. talking about what happened in
the meeting did you tell your father
anything about that
it was such a nothing there was nothing
to tell me I wouldn't even remembered it
until we start scouring through the
stuff it was it was literally just a
wasted twenty minutes which was a shame
okay so it's a wasted 20 minutes now
this is believable right I mean like he
looks like he's telling the truth here
but I will just remind you that Hillary
Clinton said this about Loretta Lynch's
meeting with Bill Clinton they talked
about grandkid thank you very much on
our minds these days
golf said a mutual friend former
attorney General Janet Reno it was
purely social they did not just a year
off of speaking about those kinds of you
know very common exchanger okay so I'm
not suggesting that Donald Trump jr. is
definitely lying because I don't know
whether he's lying or not what I will
say is that if Hillary Clinton had done
the exact same thing would have said
there's no way she's telling the truth
right Bill Clinton Loretta Lynch don't
get together in a room but we in the
middle of the campaign to talk about
grandkids right we all said that this is
complete nonsense and it turns out that
it did compromise the investigation in
in such a way that James Comey felt the
necessity to actually get himself
involved in the investigation where he
had no place if we're going to hold the
standard that we don't know what happens
behind closed doors and we have to be
suspicious my feeling is that we have to
be pretty consistent about this so
that's question number one did any
information actually change hands
because that would actually be
successful collusion not just attempted
collusion second who approved Donald
Trump jr. statements so on Saturday I
know listen I'm trying to be the most
honest take I can hear so as I say no
crime was committed it's not clear to me
that Donald Trump jr. did anything you
know legally I don't think I did
anything wrong legally wrong anyway it's
not treason as the leftist proclaiming
but to pretend that this is a big
nothing burger is being dishonest I
think when people say it's nothing
burger it's because they're not actually
taking an even quasi objective looked at
this okay so on Saturday
Donald Trump jr. released a statement
about this particular meeting and here's
what he said he said quote it was a
short introductory meeting I asked Jared
and Paul to stop by we primarily
discussed a program about the adoption
of Russian children that was active and
popular with American families years ago
and was since ended by the Russian
government but it was not a campaign
issue at the time and there was no
follow-up I was asked to attend the
meeting by an acquaintance but was not
told the name of the person I would be
meeting with beforehand so
all of this is technically true right
all that's technically true but it
misses the two main points which is the
meeting was specifically held to pass on
cert about Hillary Clinton and second
Trump jr. fully expected that he was
going to be meeting a Russian government
lawyer into her name but it said right
in the email that this is going to be a
Russian government lawyer so the problem
is the New York Times is reporting that
the White House pre-approved Trump jr.
statement on Saturday which looks more
like a cover-up than it does like an
attempt to be transparent
if Trump jr. had just released the
statement that'd be one thing but for
the White House to approve a statement
that it knew was false and was going to
be debunked within 72 hours not a good
look
for the White House okay and then
there's the biggest question of all
which is did Trump himself know about
the meeting and the everybody at the
meeting says no you know Trump jr. says
no it's a little hard for me to believe
that Trump was completely out of the
loop given the fact that again all of
his top campaign officials were in a
room with this lady for half an hour two
days after he had secured the nomination
but it's possible it's possible to have
this meeting and they didn't tell him
it's possible that they wanted to shield
him actually they want to have the
preliminary meeting and then if it had
turned into something maybe they go talk
with Trump the left is trotting out this
video just so you know they're trotting
out this video on June 7th that's when
Donald Trump jr. confirmed the meeting
with the Russian official source
supposedly that was going to pass on
this devastating information about
Hillary Clinton that night like four
hours later here is what Donald Trump
said on the campaign trail to put 15 I
am going to give a major speech on
probably Monday of next week and we're
going to be discussing all of the things
that have taken place with the Clintons
I think you're going to find it very
informative and very very okay so there
are a lot of people saying he never gave
this speech right everybody I remember
when she said this everybody was
expecting him to give this big barn
burner of a speech where he tore down
Hillary Clinton he never gave it so
people were suggesting that maybe what
happened here is the Jared and Trump jr.
called them up and said hey pops we're
going to get some information and you're
going to want to hear this information
and Trump got out in front of himself
that's definitely a possibility but
that's correlation not causation again
no proof that Trump knew about what was
going on here okay this brings into
question
this is the fourth question about this
and that is why did Trump fire call me
so my theory in my working theory it's
still my working theory is that Trump
fired calling me because he knows that
he's innocent and he's ticked off that
James Comey wouldn't say that he was
innocent
even though privately Tim's coming was
saying he wasn't under investigation
because of this email there's another
plausible theory that's now gaining
ground because the councilor theory to
that was Trump fired to call me because
he was getting too close I never
believed that because there was no there
there
it's hard to believe that Trump was
going to fire him over a big nothing
right maybe he fired him because he was
mad but to fire him for getting close to
something that doesn't exist seems weird
but because of Trump Jr's involvement
now it's possible that you know Trump
tried to fire economy because maybe he
was trying to protect Donald Jr this is
the theory the left is trying to put
forward now so I believe that theory no
I don't think there's enough evidence
for that theory at all but I'm just
informing you of what the left's theory
with regard to Comey
would be like why was so innocent why
was it so urgent that Trump wanted Comey
to announce that he wasn't under FBI
investigation except that maybe he was
scared that I was going to get close to
Donald jr. okay final question and this
one is is the most interesting I think
is who week the news of this meeting in
the first place so this meaning only had
four people in it right it had the the
Russian and then it had three of trumps
campaign officials all of whom are still
working for Trump so or Manta Ford isn't
but he has no interest in revealing this
meeting because it cuts against his
attempts to distance himself from his
Russian connection so who actually
leaked the news of the meeting to the
New York Times apparently they've been
working on this for months what exactly
drove all of this the most obvious
source is obviously Corey Lewandowski so
Corey Lewandowski was technically still
the campaign manager at the time he
wasn't fired until June 20th and he
hates Manta for because a metaphor took
his place he feels like metaphor doused
at him he does not like cushion air
because he thinks that Ivanka owl stood
him and he's not a huge fan of Donald Jr
from what I understand because Donald Jr
was present at his firing so Lewandowski
has a lot of interest in revealing all
of this stuff to hurt the other three
and then Trump was talking about
flirting with Lewandowski bringing him
in bringing him back that'd be some
pretty hard-nosed ball from from Corey
Lewandowski leaking news of this meeting
that could definitely damage Trump
Lewandowski has of course denied knowing
anything about the meeting but he was
the campaign manager at that time right
this is two weeks before he was fired he
was campaign manager at the time so it's
quite possible he was even copied on the
email here's the bottom line
this whole thing opens account of warmth
the Trump administration did not want
open it's going to be very difficult to
close that can of worms particularly
when the credibility for Don Jr has been
so shot on this particular meaning now
do I think that this is all a
distraction from Trump's legislative
agenda absolutely so I think the media
are over selling it yeah I do because
instead of treating this as the first
step or treating this is a case of we
now have motive but no we don't have
means or opportunity yet the media is
treating this as The Smoking Gun right
this is the be-all end-all and it is bad
I mean I'm not gonna pretend it's not
bad but it is not everything the media
is cracking it up to be now I want to go
through what Trump jr. actually had to
say about this in just a second but
before I do that I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at the US EPA so
you're at home it's late at night and
suddenly you hear somebody trying to
bust through your front door so you go
to your safe you take out your gun and
the person busts through when you shoot
them what do you do now so everybody's
story sort of ends with and that's when
I shot the guy coming through my front
door but the reality is the police will
then come and they will probably arrest
you right there we'll take you away to
very least they'll question you it will
eat up years of your life it'll cost you
thousands of dollars any time you're in
a shooting situation you're going to
spend enormous time and money dealing
with it that's why you need to talk to
my friends over at the u.s. ECA the u.s.
concealed-carry Association right now
the u.s. ECA has made part of their
mission how to protect you after the
shooting so not only do they educate you
and train you about guns and how to use
them and when to use them to make sure
that you are legally and financially
protected for after you pull the trigger
that's the u.s. ECA and right now
they're still doing this deal even post
fourth of July they're doing the great
American giveaway and want my listeners
to know about it in honor of July 4th
which just happened last week and they
are giving away 1776 dollars worth of
guns and ammo of your choice 1776 1776
dollars worth of guns and ammo of your
choice and they're picking five winners
you can have a chance to be one of those
winners one of those five winners that
defend my family now calm defend my
family now calm and that will give you
all the information about the u.s. ETA
should join up give them your
information and then you're registered
to win at 1776 dollars in guns and ammo
so go check it out defend my family now
dot-com you can check that out right now
and again us ECA is just fantastic group
you should definitely be involved with
them okay so let's go through what Trump
jr. actually said so using on Hannity
Kennedy is is the friendly press outlet
that the Trump administration goes to
when they have a problem because they
know they're not going to get a lot of
hard bulbs which is fine I mean Obama
did the same thing with CNN and MSNBC
for legitimately years so Trump jr. said
that he would have done some things
differently which seems like the
understatement of the century
like I said in retrospect I probably
would have done things a little
differently again this is before the
Russia mania this is before they were
building it up in the press for me this
was opposition research they had
something you know maybe concrete
evidence to all the stories I'd been
hearing about but they were probably
underreported for you know years not
just during the campaign so I think I
wanted to hear it out but really it went
nowhere and it was apparent that that
wasn't what the meeting was actually
about okay so basically here he is just
jobless right jobless from Arrested
Development there's a huge mistake hey
that's a there are a lot of comparisons
being made to between Joe Bluth and John
jr. last night you had done some things
differently yeah that would been good I
mean first of all if you're going to
engage in this sort of subterfuge then
perhaps you shouldn't put it in open the
email that seems like not a good way to
do it
Trump jr. then says if there'd been
anything illegal I would have gone to
the authorities right away I said it
earlier a hundred percent I would bring
it to the proper authorities so there's
nothing that I would do to ever endanger
this country I think the reason we
fought so hard during this campaign
whether it was my father and the work
that he put into it whether it was the
rest of our family and the efforts that
we put into it and you know those
efforts well because we'd do anything
for this country so we're never going to
put that in jeopardy everything okay so
the other comparison is being made with
with John Jr today is of course Fredo
Corleone
that's if Donald is the Don then then
unfortunately done jr. is Fredo
[Music]
so yeah it hasn't been a good 24 hours
for John Jr okay so now I want to go to
what the Democrats are saying about all
of this because the Democrats are saying
about all of this is full-scale nutty so
as I say I think that there's a little
more nuance than Democrats are saying
number one it is attempted collusion
okay to pretend anything otherwise is
stupid
it is attempted collusion because
clearly there is willingness on the part
of the Trump campaign to meet with the
Russian government
official or what they perceive to be a
Russian government official to pass on
Hillary's information I'm sorry about
whether that's moral or not in a second
look that's okay or not in a few minutes
because that is the the lurking question
underneath all of us is how far is the
right willing to go to defeat Hillary
Clinton and the Democrats is that okay
is it okay to work with the Russian
government to take down Tillery Clinton
because I'm already starting to see the
the shades of Jack Nicholson in a few
good men you can write ordered the Code
Red you know that's like we're almost
there
we're almost to the point where they're
a bunch of people on the right who are
basically saying okay so fine so there
was collusion what do I care you want
did they
we'll talk about that in just a second
but the Democrats are of course doing
what they always do which is blowing
this way out of proportion it's one of
the reasons why Americans can't take all
of the super seriously because they're
not waiting for the evidence so Tim
Kaine as you recall the vice
presidential candidate one of the most
quickly forgotten vice presidential
candidates in human history actually
knee recall that he ran against Hillary
he ran with Hillary Clinton and it was
basically Hillary Clinton and in this
bag of white paint and so that was the
bag boy paint being campaign here is
here is Tim Kaine talking about how this
is treason treason you think the first
reason that the investigation it's not
nothing is proven yet but we're now
beyond obstruction of justice in terms
of what's being investigated this is
moving into perjury false statements and
even in the potentially treason okay a
ninja treason here is the constitutional
definition of treason article 3 section
4 a treason against the United States
shall consist only in levying war
against them or in adhering to their
enemies giving them aid and comfort no
person shall be convicted of treason
unless on the testimony of two witnesses
to the same overt act or on confession
in open court
no we're okay we're not actually going
to send Don Jr to the electric chair
over having a meeting in from tower with
a lawyer who had no information as far
as we know so that's just awesome so so
yes the Democrats are of course making
mockery of themselves because they
cannot take a win they cannot just sit
there and take a win they of course have
to blow it out of proportion to make
asses of themselves we'll talk more
about that plus Joe Scarborough saying
that he is leaving the Republican Party
uh but for that you're going to have to
go over to
daily wire comm and become a subscriber
for $9.99 a month you can become a
subscriber daily wired icon get the rest
of the video live and you can you can
ensure that you also get to be part of
the mailbag on Fridays which we do live
it get to see Andrew Clavin show live
you get to see Michael Noel's god help
us is going to have a show live and and
you're going to get to see that as well
right you also it can come in the annual
subscriber right now for $99 a year so
not $9.99 a month right 99 bucks a year
which is a pretty hefty discount you get
annual subscription plus you get this I
told you how you can get this you get
this magnificent tumbler this creation
of the Gods in which you can drink
nectar and be replenished you see right
here it says on it leftist here's hot or
cold because the leftist years are
indeed delicious and you can warm them
up you can keep them here you can keep
it in your car it is dishwasher safe it
is amazing so this can be yours with
just an annual subscription of $99 the
tumbler the leftist here is hot or cold
so go and check that out if you just
want to listen to the show later then
you can go to iTunes or SoundCloud make
sure that you subscribe and leave us a
leave us a a comment and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we have
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so now is of course a perfect time for
the right to virtue signal so there are
a bunch of people on the right who have
decided that now is the time to virtue
signal see we told you so about Trump
okay listen I'm one of the people who is
very to put it mildly
I was rather trump skeptical during the
election cycle if you recall all the way
back then but I don't think this is an
i-told-you-so moment I don't think this
isn't a you know all these people who
voted for Trump you or don't you were so
long see what he's doing now no I think
everybody who voted for Trump basically
knew what they were getting and what
they were getting was a guy who was this
right I don't think this is a huge
enormous shock I think that you know
this is this is basically he bought what
you paid for and maybe it was better
than Hillary Clinton but it comes along
with some baggage you have to recognize
that one of the great ironies is Joe
Scarborough over on MSNBC he says that
he has done with the Republican Party
he's leaving he and mica they've had it
they're leaving mica was never a member
of the Republican Party but he's on with
Stephen Colbert one of the great
Schmucks in Showtime and and here is and
here is Joe Scarborough apparently
decided to copy the hairstyle of Andrew
Garfield from any number of movies and
or to simply get out of the shower rub
his hair with a towel and or substitute
a brillo pad for his hair he's got the
do fro going actually here is here is
night magicians definitely for going
here is Joe Scarborough explaining why
he's leaving the Republican Party like
any of us truly care desperately what do
you think is happening with your own
party I think it's I think it's
inexplicable I hold on as well as for
Donald is it inexplicable Joseph a
Scarborough is it truly inexplicable
Josefina agh Scarborough is it you spent
the entire election cycle pumping up
Donald Trump you spent the election
cycle talking about how the American
people just didn't get the appeal of
Donald Trump you had him on your show
every morning you had him call in you
sat in a room with him during the
primary results coming in and you
chortled with him and now you turn
around and oh he's so mean because he
was mean to me cos face
oh okay so as I say everyone knew what
they were getting there are very few
surprises in politics if you're
surprised by anything that is currently
going on with the Trump White House let
me suggest that you were blinding
yourself to reality before you didn't
this stuff and the same is true for Joe
Scarborough but I thought Donald Trump
was my best friend he wasn't your best
friend dude okay I thought that the
Republicans were all going to turn on
him really you didn't but here's Joe
Scarborough a three-term Congress person
who's made a fortune being an iconoclast
and here he is talking about how he's
going to leave the Republican Party
maybe he'll start his own party the Joe
and meek a wedding party it'll be
awesome
Trump was elected president but my party
has betrayed their core values time and
time and time again they turned the
other way and they're doing the same
thing now and it's actually discussing
and you have to ask yourself what
exactly is a Republican Party willing to
do how far they willing to go how much
of this country and our values are they
willing to sell out but aren't you a
Republican I am a Republican but I'm not
going to be a Republican anymore I've
got to become an independent yay and the
crowd goes nuts so thank you for that
virtue signaling Joe Scarborough not
you're not going to stay inside the
Republican Party and fight for the soul
of it if you really think all these
things you're not going to try and
correct the mistakes you're not going to
try and win people over to your side
you're going to leave the Republican
Party all together and this is what the
left wants right with the left actually
won so they're calling for is for
everyone who doesn't like the stuff that
they are seeing from from right and I
don't like the stuff I'm saying from
from junior I don't like a lot I mean I
think I've been pretty clear about what
I think Trump is good when he's bad
right we've done good from bad from for
nigh on two years at this point so I've
been pretty clear about this my goal is
to make Trump a better president at this
point my goal is to make the
conservative movement a better
conservative movement at this point it
isn't to leave and dump all over the
movement because I have to signal to
everybody what a swell guy I am the web
keeps saying well if you really want to
resist from Y don't resist his agenda
well what his agenda is wrong I will
resist it but if you if you think that
I'm going to want to raise taxes and
increase Medicaid spending because I
think that Trump is sometimes a jerk and
I think term maton be sometimes be
corrupt if you think that like I just
want to know when was last time a
Democrat left Bill Clinton's agenda
behind because Bill Clinton was a sleazy
scumbag like when was when was the last
time the Democrats decide you know what
I can't take all these lives from Obama
I'm becoming a Republican
that's not what people do okay so this
is just a way to please that crowd over
at Stephen Colbert so virtue signalling
from people like Joe Scarborough so how
is the write responding to all of this
there are really four approaches on the
right to all of this approach number one
is to focus on the legality people
saying listen this is not illegal okay
no matter what you say this is not
illegal so Jeffrey Toobin who's not even
on the right he is the lefty legal
commentator on CNN he makes the point
and he is correct this is not illegal
activity by Donald Trump jr. as far as
we know how serious is this these emails
from a legal perspective it's certainly
very very serious but it's also
important to say you know there is a
long way to go and these emails in and
of themselves are not proof of any
crimes two things to think about one is
it is a crime for campaign officials to
solicit anything of value from a foreign
government so the question is was
anything solicited here of value were
that were email solicited was hacking
solicited that is the question
investigators will want to explore the
other issue is the Jared Kushner who is
now a very high White House official
he's copied on these emails the question
is did he disclose these meeting this
meeting to when he filled out his form
applying for security clearance if he
intentionally left it off that's a crime
it's not a crime if he simply forgot or
made a mistake
this meeting though certainly seems
pretty dramatic even in the context of a
dramatic campaign the idea that he
simply forgot about it strikes me as
probably a little hard to believe okay
fine so he's going after Jared but
Donald Trump jr. didn't break any laws
as far as we know even Jeffrey Toobin is
admitting that so this defense that it's
not illegal is correct I point out once
again illegal does not mean moral okay
so if it's not illegal that doesn't mean
that he did something good and it also
doesn't mean he didn't do something that
could get his dad engaged so Democrats
we're going to try to impeach from no
matter what but this does not help okay
approach number two is the what app what
about ISM I talked about at the top of
the show and that is the what about
Obama right what about Obama and here is
Ted Cruz talking about President Obama
and why it is maybe I are ignoring all
this stuff
I think that we have had eight years of
Barack Obama showing nothing but
appeasement towards Russia okay and that
is a hundred percent true the question
is the question is what kind of what
about is are we going to engage in so I
think that it is fair to say to the
media you guys are hypocrites right
you're over the top coverage of this
just demonstrates how leftist you are so
the critique is not of Hillary so much
as it is of the media coverage right why
is the media coverage so over-the-top
about Trump but when it comes to when it
comes to Hillary Clinton they were
willing to brush all this stuff under
the table and comes to Obama they're
the table that is an effective form of
what about ISM what is not an effective
form is Donald Trump jr. did something
bad but Hillary also did stuff that was
bad and that wasn't a big deal so why
should this be a big deal right that is
the kindergarten version that when your
kid comes home and it turns out that
they but they did something bad they
said well Billy did it too and so I
don't care what Billy did why does that
make any difference you know that's like
this is stuff that we learned when we
were in kindergarten but I just we now
have to relearn it in politics okay so
that is approach number two is what
about the Democrats okay the Democrats
are terrible now is this good right
that's still a question that has to be
asked and we have to decide that for
ourselves is it something good I'm gonna
get to that in a second approach number
three is can we talk about the real
issues right that is this isn't that big
a deal right the proportionality
argument this isn't that huge a deal
okay so they took a meeting what's the
big deal
Hillary Clinton did it about Ukraine no
one complained about that now they're
artisan there's one distinction which is
the Ukrainian government is not
adversarial to the United States with
the Russian government is and the
Russian government was indeed trying to
intervene in the election even in ways
the Ukrainian government was not but
this is not a bad line so Sebastian
Gorica who's a White House foreign
policy adviser he says why aren't we
talking about like a huge news story
that happened yesterday which is the
defeat of Isis in Mosul don't you think
it's time the American people were
served by the media justly and you get
to national security issues like Mosul
we're going to get to most in one minute
mr. Gargan
he's right when and the answer is never
they're never going to get to Mosul so
this I think is a good approach I think
Republicans should be saying to the
media why don't you cover this stuff
they should also be saying Trump do just
ignore all of this same Muller's
investigating it'll take it's quite like
I've been I've been singing the same
tune on this for months now okay all
Trump past
a is sit on it you don't think it's
course it's being investigated don't
worry about it we'll get to it now look
at all this magnificent stuff I'm doing
instead what Trump does is he unleashes
a tweet storm about the investigation
and then at the end he tacks on and why
don't we focus on Mosul
it doesn't work that way he's the
president he gets to help set the agenda
if he is hiding in the White House for
the past three days he hasn't done any
public events instead of out there on
the trail talking about Mosel how are we
supposed to know about Mosel he is right
the media is adversarial to trump they
want to destroy Trump
Kennedy's destroyed Trump media meme is
not wrong okay I think Shawn's wrong on
some stuff I don't think he's wrong on
this I think the media do want to
destroy Trump but it is Trump's
responsibility to fight back using the
best tools at his disposal and that is
not okay I'm going to go out I'm going
to argue with Bob Bob Muller it's I'm
going to go out and I'm going to talk
about Mosel incessantly I'm going to
provide a counselor narrative and the
counter narrative is we are doing things
things are getting done and the media
won't talk about them because they
prefer to distract you over here right
this is I think the best line that
Republicans can use on this and also
we're going to be as transparent as we
can be okay then there is the final
approach and this is the most morally
perilous approach okay this is an
approach taken by my good friend John
Nolte now a published Nolte over at
Daily wire and one of the reasons I like
publishing loyalty even though we have
almost polar opposite opinions on these
issues is because Nolte is very clear
about what he wants right no if he does
not try to hide the ball John is an
honest guy he's honest enough to
acknowledge what his argument is and the
ramifications of that argument I want to
read to you from know peas piece today
on this on this story so he says the
worst that Donald's from from your
scandal gets the more I know Republican
voters chose the right guy to run
against Hillary Clinton in 2016 at first
it looks as though the meeting in the
question was something over to over
something touchy-feely like adoption
upon hearing that my first thought was
wait you've just secured the nomination
and the first thing you do is pull the
campaign manager and Donald whisper into
a meeting about adoption are you insane
no kidding I was furious hey when the
future of the country is at stake and
you are up against the unholy trinity of
the Clinton machine the entire
mainstream media complex and their
butthurt allies and never Trump there is
no time to waste but then the truth came
out we learned that the meeting was set
up in the hopes of receiving information
from the Russian government that would
ensure Hillary Clinton never ever ever
became president and my faith in the
epic badassery of team Trump was
restored maybe even bolstered okay this
is why I love John I loved
John because John just says what he
thinks right he's not going to try and
hide it so a lot of people on the right
will deny that this is what they think
but what John says is actually
indicative of a large percentage of what
Republicans think this Trump world is
populated with people who will do
anything anything to win and as long as
it remains legal those are my kind of
Republicans Oh grow up seriously y'all
grow the hell up I understand there are
a lot of people who listen to the show
who agree with this perspective the
reason I disagree with this perspective
is because I think that it does walk
into dicey moral territory and I'm sorry
I bring up things like principles and
morality in the context of this but I
thought that politics was about
upholding principle now you can say myq
principle is beating Hillary Clinton but
there are still rules and engagement so
for example I assume that John would not
be in favor of somebody walking into
Hillary Clinton's office and shooting
her to stop her from becoming president
even if she's the existential threat
John thinks she was to the country I'm
fairly certain that John is not in favor
of the use of violence my guess is that
there would be other things that John
would not be in favor of like if you
were going to set Hillary Clinton up in
some sort of sexual peccadilloes sting
right you're going to you're going to
entice her into something John might
find that abhorrent maybe not maybe not
but I think that we need to know what
the rules of engagement are because
otherwise we're gonna get into some
pretty dicey territory however evil you
say your opponent is however destructive
you say your opponent is that helps
justify whatever action you take what
makes a person immoral is when your
means are not geared to your end
so someone cuts you off in traffic get
out of your car and you beat them to
death with a baseball bat this makes you
an amoral evil person because the
consequence
did not meet the bad act right someone
cut you off in traffic does not merit
being beaten to death with a baseball
bat
now someone attempts to kill your child
that merits you beating them to death
with a baseball bat right so the same
act can be moral or immoral based on
what it is done in response to the
problem is that in politics we are now
reaching the point where the most
political benefit can be gained if you
say my political enemy is Hitler my
political enemy is the worst person ever
but that also means that you're going to
be using outsize modes of defeating that
person right you're willing to now
cooperate with one of the worst people
on planet earth Lattimer Putin in order
to stop who you perceived to be the
worst person on planet or Hillary
Clinton right Vladimir Putin is less
threatening to you and less threatening
to the world
Hilary Clinton so Hillary Clinton must
be stopped that justifies anything and
everything up to and including Russia
Russian involvement now let's say for
example and this is obviously not true
let's say that there was a situation
where Isis had some sort of damaging
information on Hillary Clinton she knew
that they knew that she had shipped guns
to them or something and they went to
the Trump campaign and they said here's
the information on Hillary Clinton would
people on the right go along with that
well it depends how bad they think
Hillary Clinton is because maybe the
means are OK in order to stop Hillary
Clinton here's my view of Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton was a uniquely
damaging figure in American public life
Hillary Clinton was a uniquely dangerous
character it's why I found her so
unpalatable that I would not vote for
either her or Donald Trump right I did
not there was not a point in the
campaign where I talked up Hillary
Clinton none I thought Hillary Clinton
would be a disaster for the country I
did not think Hillary Clinton however
was Vladimir Putin which means that the
methods I was willing to use were
restricted to things like truth and not
cooperating with Russia and engaging in
certain means that were that were
dedicated to or defeating her here's the
truth the easiest way to defeat Hillary
Clinton was to side with Russia the
easiest way to defeat Hillary Clinton
might have been a shooter but I wasn't
in favor of any of those things because
I think that's immoral in politics the
easiest way to defeat somebody is to
have no rules this is why so many people
on the right like Trump but having no
rules can be immoral if you are miss
calibrating the threat of your opponent
a Hillary Clinton is still an American
Hillary Clinton may be a bad bad person
you may believe bad bad things you may
want to do bad bad things but I still
don't think that justifies cooperating
with an enemy of the United States and
Russia in order to take Hillary
Clinton's down nor do I think it's
necessary nor do I think it's necessary
I think Donald's from very well kind of
taking down Hillary Clinton without
Russia how do I know that because I
think that's what he did I think the
Donald Trump defeated her without
colluding with Russia
so this bizarre perception by people
that Donald Trump didn't collude with
Russia but if you tried to that's
awesome because it just shows how far he
was willing to go he didn't need to do
that okay that's like saying I want to
stop people from cutting me off in
traffic I beat him to death with a
baseball bat
I didn't have to beat him to death with
a baseball bat I probably just yelled at
him and flipped him off or maybe honk my
horn but I beat him to death with a
baseball bat and you know what what
makes me so cool is even if I didn't
beat him to death as a baseball that I
was willing to beat him to death with a
baseball bat
no the means have to
be calibrated to the ends and you also
have to honestly judge this listen me
saying that I think Hillary Clinton is
not Vladimir Putin is not talking up
Hillary Clinton but it shows how
ridiculous our political discourse has
become that if I say something like that
people on my own side will say that this
is me being soft on Hillary I don't
think that Hillary Clinton has to be
Hitler in order to think that Hillary
Clinton is a bad human being who never
should have been within a thousand feet
of the White House and to that's you
know I think that we have to be very
careful about this because our own
mortal Souls are in danger and if you
think that that's not at risk if you
think that we can be as bad as anybody
else if we can just use any means then I
ask where you draw the line because
you're asking the left to draw some line
so I would ask for you to draw some more
lines yourself okay time for things I
like and then things I hate will do a
little bit of Bible talk but before we
get to that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over upside comm so
you travel for business I travel for
business a lot when I travel for
business very often I'm traveling by
myself
and the best way to get a loan ticket
for business travel is it upside calm
this is where they specialize so you go
to upside calm and they will give you a
bunch of different rates based on where
you are flying what time you're flying
they'll give you you know different
hotels and then they give you these
amazing discounts because they are they
are bundling your flight in your hotel
and by bundling that they are getting
you the lowest possible rate but they
have you gives you something else too
when you experience that upside
difference they also give you an Amazon
gift card every time you buy a trip you
get an Amazon gift card every time you
buy a trip the average Amazon gift card
that you will receive is 150 dollars not
everyone gets that so I'm getting more
some get less but $150 is the average
Amazon gift card that you get to you
personally when you buy a business room
so you go on use your company's credit
card for your for your business trip and
that you personally get the Amazon gift
card which as I say the average gift
card that you get from working with
upside is 150 dollars it is the real
deal try it right now upside calm and
when you use the promo code Bend then
you are guaranteed that you're going to
get an Amazon gift card on your first
trip again the average gift card is 150
dollars upside calm is the better way to
buy business travel a minimum purchase
is required and you should see the site
for complete details and go check it out
upside calm the best way to travel okay
time for things I like things I hate and
then we'll do
a very very brief Bible talk so things I
like so since we mentioned Joe Bluth I
just have to say Arrested Development
have I recommend to the restive element
on the ship for Arrested Development is
the plenty of series that ever was
home's Arrested Development is
absolutely hilarious you have to have a
very quirky sense of humor to get it job
is maybe the best character on the show
job is the the kind of there there are
three brothers there is Michael and is
it Michael is that his name and then job
and then what Buster that's right and
it's been probably a couple years since
I've watched the show and there it's
just the cast is phenomenal hilarious
it's full of references that you end up
using with your friends here is a clip
for this from the opening episode of
Arrested Development when you first meet
Joe Bluth job stands for George and then
his middle initial was oh and then it so
it's gob Bluth but he's called job which
of course is a play on the fact that
like everything bad in the world happens
to job in the course of the show so here
is here's govt here's Joe Bluth
this is Michael's oldest brother oh poor
job this is the magic trick huh lusion
Michael trick is something a four-dose
for money
who's the kid standing right next to me
it's okay Joe recently founded the
Alliance of magicians an organization
that blackballs any performer who
reveals a magician secret hello I'm Joe
glue as a magician I can make a lot of
things disappear there are some things I
can't make no not that candy ball
machine the aspect to what box box is
performing in buildings oh yes well
let's get you in the box there's a panel
just for there round circle of mind it
don't make any noise all right ancient
lore has it the Aztec gods put a curse
on any man who does he go
George Michael was off from school for
two weeks and was enjoying spending time
with his uncle intercepting some
telepathic energy it's telling me the
eight of diamonds that's amazingly close
gee I got it wrong oh yes you won the
shirt on my back okay that's a man queen
of diamonds just the queen of diamonds
no no no well I had I mean if that had
been the actual card I'm pretty sure I'd
be almost it's too blown away
I was just amazing the hilarious show
you should go check it out
the Netflix Netflix did a fifth season
to their four original seasons and then
it was not on three okay so the fourth
is the Netflix season the original three
seasons are great I can't speak for the
fourth season I watched the first two
episodes they didn't hold up I'll have
to watch the rest of the season until I
fit holds up but it is just like it's a
hysterically funny show okay time for a
thing that I hate so Joan Walsh she used
to be the editor over at salon.com she
was on the MSNBC s and she said that
Ivanka who as you recall took papa
Trump's place at the g20 she sat in his
seat and people were like wait a second
we didn't we didn't elect Trump so we
get a vodka in that seat that's a decent
criticism but Joan Walsh makes a not so
decent criticism
here's her criticism of Ivanka Trump
which is legitimately the stupidest
criticism of all time I thought that was
a very sink dress with sig's big bows on
the elbows there's something incredibly
ornamental that's not a dress that's
made for work that's not a dress that's
made to go out in the world and make a
difference that is a dress that is
designed to show off you're growing this
and you know god bless her show it off
but don't then tell us that you're
crusading for an equal place for women
at the table because you're not but you
can't be a feminist and be girly at the
same time it can be a feminist and be
girly we all have our girlie days but I
think showing up taking your father's
seat in a pink dress with big bows on
the sleeves is a really an interesting
method really okay maybe maybe Joan
Walsh
should force a fountain Trump to wear I
don't like a red cloak and maybe like a
bonnet right and then she can like walk
around in that and Joan can call her up
Joan then she can be known as of Joan
that would just be Ivanka Trump's name
okay this is how insane the feminist
movement has become so a woman so
powerful that she sat in for the
President of the United States at an
international conference she is not
powerful because she has bows on her
sleeve and this is your lead critique
Joan Walsh and then you wonder why we
think feminists are a joke we think
feminists are a joke because of people
like you because that's ridiculous
okay that is insane women can look
pretty and also be feminist at the same
time my wife does it everything
day she's super smokin hot and she wears
pretty clothes a lot and she is a doctor
as I've mentioned 1 bajillion times on
this program she is fully capable of
being a feminist and dressing like a
beautiful woman this idea they have to
dress like a hag in order to be a
feminist is not going to forward the
feminist cause very much boy oh boy Joan
Walsh okay finally I am going to do a
quick quick Bible talk so this week is
the Jewish portion of pin cast from the
Torah Thursday as I say every week now
there is an Associated portion from the
from the prophets and the writings that
we read every week as well this one
happens to be from the Book of Jeremiah
and this of course is one of more famous
verses from the Book of Jeremiah and it
says it says when I had not yet formed
you in the womb I knew you and and when
you had not yet emerged from a woman had
appointed you a prophet to the nation's
I made you this is of course used by the
pro-life movement to point out that your
existence as a human being predates your
emergence from the womb of course that
is true the idea is that God provides
you value from the very very beginning
and God knows you as a human being from
the very very beginning and you are
predestined to have a certain skill set
but as we see all throughout Tanakh
because we see all throughout the Torah
and the prophets and the writings and
the New Testament as well just because
God has foreordained a particular a
particular job for you doesn't mean that
you're necessarily going to fulfill it
so there are two points two major one is
that God knows you and he knows you well
enough to know what he expects of you
that's what it means when it says when I
had formed you in way not yet formed you
in the womb I knew you I knew what to
expect of you because I'm the one who
created you and I appointed you when you
had a responsibility I made you a
prophet to the nation's but we still
have the choice whether to fulfill that
responsibility ourselves this is where
that moral choice comes in the fact is
that Jeremiah could have decided not to
fulfill that plan and he would have been
sinning against God in doing so right
this is the story of Jonah when Jonah
refuses to take God's message for for at
face value and he tries to run away from
God he's unable to escape it but he does
have the choice to attempt to avoid it
we all have that choice but that's a
choice that we should not make because
God knows that's even better than we
know ourselves okay
so we'll be back here tomorrow with all
of the latest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
you